dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir finally I have
been waiting for quite a while to cover
this amazing paper which is about alpha
zero we have talked about alpha zero
before this is an AI that is able to
play chess go and shogi or in other
words Japanese chess on a remarkably
high level I will immediately start out
by uttering the main point of this work
the point of alpha zero is not to solve
chess or any of these games its main
point is to show that the general AI can
be created that can perform on a
superhuman level on not one but several
different tasks at the same time let's
have a look at this image where you see
a small part of the evaluation of alpha
zero versus stockfish an amazing
open-source chess engine which has been
consistently at or around the top
computer chess players for many years
now stockfish has an e low rating of
over 3200 which means that it has a win
rate of over 90% against the best human
players in the world now interestingly
comparing these algorithms is nowhere
near as easy as it sounds this sounds
curious so why is that for instance it
is not enough to pit the two algorithms
against each other and see who ends up
winning it matters what version of
stockfish is used how many positions are
the machines allowed to evaluate how
much thinking time they are allowed the
size of hash tables the hardware being
used the number of threads being used
and so on from the side of the chess
community these are the details that
matter however from the side of the AI
researcher what matters most is to
create a general algorithm that can play
several different games on a superhuman
level with this constraint it would
really be a miracle if alpha zero were
able to even put up a good fight against
dogfish so what happened alpha
played a lot of games that ended up as
drawers again stock fish and not only
that but whenever there was a winner it
was almost always off a zero insanity
and what is quite remarkable is that
alpha zero has only trained for four to
seven hours only through self play
comparatively the development of the
current version of stock fish took more
than 10 years you can see how reliably
this AI can be trained the blue lines
show the results of several training
runs and they all converge to the same
result with only a tiny bit of deviation
alpha zero is also not a brute-force
algorithm as it evaluates fewer
positions per second than stockfish
Kasparov put it really well in his
article where he said that alpha zero
works smarter and not harder than
previous techniques even magnus carson
chess master extraordinaire said in an
interview that during his games he often
thinks what would alpha zero do in this
case which i found to be quite
remarkable Kasparov also had many good
things to say about the new alpha zero
in a let's say very casper of esque
manner and also note that the key point
is not whether the current version of
stockfish or the one from two months ago
was used the key point is that stockfish
is a brilliant chess engine but it is
not able to play go or any game other
than chess this is the main contribution
that deepmind was looking for with this
work this AI can master three games at
once and a few more papers down the line
it may be able to master any perfect
information game all my goodness what a
time to be alive we have only scratched
the surface in this video this was only
a taste of the paper the evaluation
section in the paper is out of this
world so make sure to have a look in the
video description and I am convinced
that nearly any questions one can
possibly think of is addressed there i
also link to Kasparov's editorial on
this topic it is short and very readable
give it a go I hope this little taste of
alpha zero inspires you to go out there
and explore yourself this is the main
message of this series let me know in
the comments what you think or if you
found some cool other things related to
alpha zero thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time